buried here deep in a Japanese Mountain
Pass is one of the world's rarest
Technologies a 43 kilometer long
magnetic levitation train track which
will eventually become part of the
world's first inter-city maglev train
connecting Tokyo and Osaka with the
power of superconducting magnets these
trains hover a mere 10 centimeters above
their track while pummeling along at a
mind-boggling speed of 500 kilometers
per hour with no physical contact with
the track they can operate in any
weather condition and have lower
maintenance costs due to reduced
friction and fewer moving Parts despite
the advantages of maglev trains over
traditional high-speed trains the only
commercial high-speed maglev line
currently in operation is just 30
kilometers long connecting Shanghai
airport to its City a journey the train
makes in only 8 minutes but a track this
short largely defeats the advantage
high-speed maglev by the time the train
gets up to speed it needs to slow down
again a 30 kilometer long journey in 8
minutes actually equates to an average
speed of 225 kilometers per hour slower
than the top speed of conventional
High-Speed Rail the planned future
network of high-speed maglev trains is
just 400 kilometers long and it pales in
comparison to the extensive network of
60 000 kilometers of regular high-speed
train tracks already in place around the
world with an additional 50 000
kilometers under construction why is
this Gap so large let's delve deeper
into how maglev trains work and explore
the reasons behind the restricted
deployment
thank you
we have two primary methods of
levitating a train we can pull the train
up using attractive forces or push the
train upward using repulsive forces the
pulling approach involves a combination
of a magnetic iron Rail and an
electromagnet that uses attractive
forces to raise the body of the train
this is an active system where the gap
between the rail and the magnet is
crucial as the strength of the
attractive Force decreases with the
square of the distance meaning the train
needs active controls and feedback loops
to ensure that these gaps stay between 8
and 12 millimeters if the train begins
to drop the magnetic force holding it up
will quickly weaken causing it to fall
even further it's an unstable
configuration these types of trains are
referred to as electromagnetic
suspension trains this is the system the
30 kilometer line in Shanghai uses Japan
opted to use a different system with a
more significant gap of 10 centimeters
between the track and train eight times
greater than the gap for electromagnetic
suspension while also providing a
passively stable method of levitation a
vital property to have in the earthquake
prone region in this approach magnets on
board the train interact with passive
coils on the track as the train moves
over these coils they experience a
changing magnetic field which generates
the opposing field that lists the train
upward if the train is stationary on top
of the coils there is no change in the
magnetic field so this dynamic system
only works when the train is already
going fast the trains have wheels that
drop down when the train is slowing down
but flip into the carriage when they
reach 100 kilometers per hour in order
to achieve a stable position on the
track the North and South poles are
arranged vertically on the sides of the
track the magnets are formed from coils
of wire arranged in a figure eight
pattern a South Pole points up on one
side while the North Pole points up on
the other if the train were to drop
slightly or move sideways the magnets on
the train induced currents on the
opposite coils generating a stronger
magnetic field which pushes the train
back to the midpoint of the figure eight
shapes this dynamic system is forgiving
with the 10 centimeter gaps between the
track and the train naturally maintained
with no need for complex control inputs
however the Japanese maglev train called
Lo will be the first of its kind these
trains known as SC maglevs need
superconducting coils to generate the
extremely powerful permanent magnetic
field on the train these are the coils
that induce the changing magnetic field
and allow the train to level rotate in a
stable configuration these coils located
on each side of the carriage must be
maintained below their critical
temperature to ensure their currents
flow without resistance the neobium
titanium coils are cooled using liquid
helium and placed inside a container
that is cooled by liquid nitrogen the
coils are cooled using a pulse tube
refrigerator which uses sound waves to
cool the helium the same type of
refrigeration cycle that the James Webb
Telescope is using to keep its infrared
sensors cold enough to detect even the
faintest infrared heat radiation from
the distant past a sound wave is just a
pressure wave and pressure and
temperature are directly proportional
higher pressure will cause higher
temperature we can take advantage of
this by creating a standing wave where
the Peaks and troughs of the wave are
stationary we can do this in a closed
tube where the resonant frequency of the
tube is determined by the tube's length
here the sound wave will bounce off the
closed end and create a region of
compression and high pressure and
therefore high temperature we can now
place a stack that spans this hot region
at the end of the tube to the cold
region at the center now if we place a
heat exchanger on either end of the
stack we can now transfer the heat to a
radiator and the cold side will conduct
heat away from the superconducting coils
keeping them cold there are eight of
these coils per car with four on each
side however having a magnetic field
strength of this magnitude right next to
the passengers and traveling by at half
the speed of sound could cause some
serious problems ferrous objects aren't
allowed anywhere near MRI machines the
engineers needed to find a way to ensure
the magnetic field did not extend into
the passenger's carbon or far away from
the train we can't block magnetic fields
but we can redirect them in the same way
we can conduct electricity to where we
want it to go using copper wires where
we use the ease of passage for an
electric current with resistance we
measure the ease of passage for a
magnetic field with reluctance where
copper has a low resistance iron has a
low reluctance we can use electric Steel
shielding to diverse the magnetic field
away from the cabin and stations
electric steel contains three percent
silicon and is post-processed to produce
large Crystal grains aligned in a
specific Direction which is controlled
by a cold rolling process the grain
oriented electric steel can carry about
30 percent more magnetic flux in this
direction allowing Engineers to direct
the magnetic flux in the desired
Direction however this Shield is heavy
so we want to use as little of it as
possible luckily we can also tailor the
magnetic field shape through careful
design of the magnets themselves if we
place two parallel magnets like this
North Poles aligned horizontally the
magnetic flux lines would run parallel
to the magnets and be denser between the
magnets however if we flip one of them
the magnetic flux lines connect up and
create a kind of bubble in between them
the magnetic field will be weaker in
this location
this is how we arrange the coils on
either side of the cabin there are four
sets of coils on each side so we also
need to flip the magnets so the North
and South poles are facing each other
this creates a low magnetic field bubble
through the corridors with the use of
shielding the field strength is reduced
to only 0.5 Milli Tesla almost
equivalent to the Earth's magnetic field
of course near the magnets the field
strength is unavoidably high and this
prevents us from using certain materials
in those areas the tracks for example
need to be constructed from low magnetic
steel or Fiber reinforced Composites but
how does a levitating train Propel
itself if it's not touching the ground
for conventional rail we just apply a
torque to the wheels that will push off
against the ground wheels are actually a
bit of a middleman in the development of
toric many trains already use electric
motors to turn their wheels the electric
motors use electromagnetic force to turn
a shaft what if we could take the same
motor and unrapis this is called a
linear motor where alternating coils
attract and repel the train with precise
timing to a break the trains can use
this system in Reverse this is
regenerative braking since
electrodynamic systems don't work at low
speed they also have brakes for their
wheels the trains also feature an air
brake that can slow the train down very
effectively at top speeds there is one
other challenge when dealing with
contactless trains how do they get
electricity for lower speed maglev
systems they use a low friction third
rail common in Metro systems to bring
electricity to the trains but as speeds
get higher this isn't practical as it
defeats the purpose of reducing friction
from the rails some early versions of
the Japanese style electrodynamic system
actually had a gas turbine on board to
provide Power but it now uses a linear
induction coil to collect power from the
changing magnetic field from The Guiding
coils this does create a magnetic drag
Force but it's more effective than
carrying a large generator on board the
Japanese line is set to be the first
long-distance high-speed maglev train
its first phase covering 285 kilometers
will connect Tokyo to Nagoya and is
scheduled to open by 2027. the second
phase which will complete the remaining
438 kilometers to Osaka is expected to
be completed a decade later so why is
Japan pursuing this futuristic
technology Japan has long been at the
Forefront of train technology after
opening their Tokyo to Osaka shinkansen
line in 1964 the world's first
high-speed train they immediately began
exploring ways to reduce the four-hour
journey to under one hour starting in
the 1970s Japan Airways and the Japanese
Central rail station constructed a seven
kilometer testing track here in Miyazaki
they began with prototypes of trains
that could reach speeds of 60 kilometers
per hour in 1972 And by 1975 they had
developed trains capable of race
reaching up to 411 kilometers per hour
as the Miyazaki test track became Too
Short The yamanashi Test Track began
Construction in 1990. this 20 kilometer
test track was conveniently located
between the cities of Tokyo and Nagoya
along the route of the upcoming new
maglev line here they transformed the
design from a prototype to a fully
functional train capable of carrying 700
passengers in 12 cars at speeds of up to
500 kilometers per hour plus high-speed
maglev trains are more than just a
science experiment they are an efficient
and super fast way to move people
building these trains is more than just
an engineering challenge it is also an
economic challenge where they have to
compete against cars planes and other
types of trains when maglevs are brought
up in the US the idea of traveling
between New York and LA in seven hours
is often used as a statement of its
potential it's the very first line on
the U.S department of Energy's own
website but a track of this length makes
little economic sense if we plot the
travel time for trains planes and cars
between say San Francisco and La two
large population centers within a
reasonable driving distance this is what
it looks like trains are outright the
best option even though planes are
faster airports are usually located far
outside the city and security wait times
increase the length of the journey a
high-speed train will save passengers
time and in turn make an economy more
productive a reduction of travel time of
two hours for 900 passengers equates to
1 800 hours equivalent to 75 days faster
trains simply extend the range at which
trains are competitive to Airlines large
cities between 200 and 800 kilometers
apart are perfect contenders for
High-Speed Rail DC to New York in just
60 minutes
this map shows the potentially
economically viable High-Speed Rail
Connections in the US unfortunately as
it stands the US is not investing much
in High-Speed Rail and maglev systems
are even harder to build they require
completely new tracks that need
electromagnetic coils along the entire
length and specialized materials that
are not affected by the incredibly
strong magnetic fields passing by them
at 500 kilometers per hour the Japanese
line that will connect Tokyo to Nagoya
recently had a price increase to 13.7
billion dollars maglevs are between 10
and 50 times more expensive than
High-Speed Rail the incredibly
successful French High-Speed Rail the
tgv built in the 80s and 90s cost 2
million dollars per kilometer the first
stage of the Japanese line is set to
cost 77 million dollars per kilometer
even when compared to the same route
from Tokyo to to Osaka via High-Speed
Rail the maglev system will cost 11.3
times more per kilometer that is a large
price to pay to reduce the travel time
by one hour the Tokyo to Nagoya line is
taking a more direct route through
mountainous terrain a staggering 86
percent of the track will be underground
tunneling over 200 kilometers
significantly increases costs
interestingly this also leads to
increased operational expenses when the
train travels in open air at speeds of
500 kilometers per hour the unobstructed
air simply moves aside however when
traveling through a tunnel the air has
no Escape Route this creates additional
drag which in turn increases the force
required to propel the train forward the
energy usage of the new line will be 30
percent higher compared to the existing
Tokyo to Osaka line but that's still
vastly better than flying for now I
don't see maglev technology being used
Beyond some special projects like this
the radical increase in costs simply do
not justify the increases and top speed
over a conventional High-Speed Rail and
it's beyond imagination for the us where
we are struggling to get regular rail
service even in places uniquely suited
to it like the Texas triangle four high
population cities located in a triangle
with only the hellscape of interstate
highways connecting them with the recent
speculation about the potential of room
temperature superconductors a technology
that would make maglev trains vastly
easier to build Interest online in
superconductor Technologies is higher
than ever
but a lot of it is unintuitive and
actually understanding how magnetic
fields work is a fantastic tool in an
engineer's Arsenal so many of our most
important Technologies depend on this
physical phenomenon but you don't have
to pay for a whole university level
course to understand the fundamentals
there is a free way you can learn about
magnetism and electricity with this
fantastic course on brilliant you can
find this and tons of other courses on
brilliant including one of their new
courses predicting with probability
understanding probability and applying
it to Everyday situations is a great
career tool but also just an everyday
Common Sense tool to help you navigate
daily decisions I highly recommend
taking this course brilliant makes
Learning Easy with fun interactive
courses that really succeed in getting
you that dopamine Rush as they test your
knowledge along the way they have a
fantastic mobile app so you can learn on
the go too brilliant has 1000 of other
lessons too AI data science neural
networks and even our very own partnered
real engineering course you can get
access to that course right now and all
of brilliant's other curated interactive
courses by going to brilliant.org
forward slash real engineering or by
clicking the link in the description you
can get started for free for 30 days and
the first 500 people to do so will get
20 off brilliant's annual premium
subscription